une injection devant les caméras pour
qu'elle soit vu par le plus grand nombre
premier ministre a bien tenté de
réconforter son épouse mais c'est avant
tout les canadiens qu'il tente de
rassurer
justin trudeau veut les convaincre de
l'importance de se faire vacciner
c'est la responsabilité des citoyens de
faire partie de la solution
le premier ministre qui a 49 ans a reçu
astrazeneca un vaccin qui a beaucoup
fait parler de lui
maintenant des experts fédéraux arrive
avec une nouvelle recommandation qu'il
soit désormais accessible aux trente ans
et plus sans contre indication
si une personne ne veut pas attendre
fire ou modern art quand on a une auto
de transmission on a beaucoup plus
d'avantagés à être vaccinés rapidement
avec l'astre est une époque de risque de
thrombose associé avec ce vaccin chaque
province prendra sa propre décision
les autorités fédérales martèle
l'importance de se faire vacciner
6 75 % des canadiens reçoivent une
première dose d'ici l'été
la belle saison pourrait être encore
plus radieuse avec la levée de certaines
restrictions amené fermeture des lieux
de travail et d'entreprises d'ici cet
été
c'est suffisamment des personnes se font
vacciner
pour contribuer à l'effort un premier
vaccin canadien pourrait être disponible
dès l'automne
l'entreprise medicago a commencé le
partage des données avec santé canada
pour son approbation
c'est aussi une grande fierté de pouvoir
faire partie la réponse promise canadien
et ottawa pense déjà à la suite
les canadiens pourraient avoir besoin
d'une troisième ou quatrième dose pour
conserver leur protection
le gouvernement annonce avoir signé des
contrats pour des dizaines de millions
d'unités de file biotech jusqu'en 2024
ils peuvent cette veyron mon dieu on va
être pris avec elle à couvert pendant
longtemps c'est possible et je pense que
les gens veulent qu'on soit préparée
pour minimiser l'impact qu'on pourrait
avoir dans un an deux justin trudeau
prépare le terrain
si les canadiens retrouvent peu à peu
leur liberté à compter de l'été le virus
lui pourrait faire partie de leur vie
encore longtemps la vigilance une
précaution aussi ici louis blu-ray radio
canada